hi I'm Evan Carmichael and I believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
so today I'm doing one of my Fiverr gigs
where review your website for five bucks
and give you some feedback and advice on
how to make it better now today it's a
repeat client that's website that I
looked at before and the owner wrote in
to say they've updated it and wanted
some new feedback on the site so let's
go check it out the website is the
blessed sitcom so let's load it up and
see what kind of advice we can give so
the first thing I noticed again here and
I think about it before is I don't know
what this company does and this is so
important when somebody comes to your
website they have to quickly understand
what it is that your product is all
about and how it benefits them otherwise
they're gonna bounce
they're gonna leave your website in
three seconds flat click back and never
come back so you've got to quickly
explain what it is that you do and what
the benefit is to the people visiting
your site so let's look at this website
again at the top I would put here some
kind of tagline so the blessed seed
means absolutely nothing to me you've
got to put something here that shows
what it is that you do okay let's go
down to look at our tag lines
welcome to the healing power of the
black seed oil 100% virgin quality
cold-pressed from highest quality seeds
no added ingredients so again you're not
telling me anything about what you do I
don't understand the benefit to me so
you're selling seeds you're selling seed
oil great how does that help me people
will not read this far they're gonna
bounce on your website and you won't
land deals you've got to switch around
this site if you want to keep this
business going and attract new people
who will take out their credit card and
buy your product but they have to
understand what it is that it does and
how it helps them let's keep reading
let's get down you got a picture here so
let's click on that see what happens so
this is an error right it's trying to go
to a different website star sunflower
studio.net it's not working so you want
to make sure everything on your website
is working especially from the homepage
right that will look bad on your company
if it's not working let's scroll down so
it looks like you have three types of
oil
black seed oil this is the oil most
companies sell it's it's a milder oil
with less content and volatile oil so
it's less pungent this makes it this
makes her tasty oil and those who not
like the pungency again I still have no
idea what this oil does so it's great
that it's less pungent but how is it
gonna help me already I've gone further
than most people will go into your
website and when you're talking about
your products you have to explain the
benefits to the people who are reading
it let's look at the next one black seed
oil this is the oil that we normally
sell it's an oil with a higher content
of volatile oil research has revealed
that most of the potent and fruitful
activities resides in this volatile oil
this makes a more punch in oil so again
I still have no idea what this oil does
right you're just talking about it but
there's no benefits to the reader who's
reading it let's look at the last one
this is an oil with the highest content
of volatile oil potentially two to four
times more powerful there's almost
particularly useful for respiratory
problems asthma colds and flu this makes
for an even more pungent oil so finally
here we have a little bit we've got a
little tiny bit where you say that it
helps you with asthma is cold and flu so
if I'm suffering from that I might be
interested in your product but you only
touch on it it's still not really
hitting me with a ton of benefits but
finally for the first time at least in
this description you're explaining it so
you got to apply that but amp it up even
more for all your products so people
quickly understand how it helps them and
which one they should pick let's keep
scrolling down to talk about the Bible
the West immune system so one of the
things that's going to come up here is
people gonna say yeah right this isn't
gonna help colds how many how many
different solutions have come on the
market that says they're going to help
cure everything but it doesn't so
looking at your comment here on the
immune system black seed oil can be used
as a healing remedy for almost every
illness that's gonna read so many red
flags with people you have got to back
that up you've got to find research
proof statistics studies that show that
in every case that you're trying to say
black seed oil is gonna work that it
does you need to back that up you can't
just leave that as one paragraph and say
it's going to help everything
are not gonna believe you people have a
pretty good BS meter and this is gonna
fail a test right now let's keep reading
when you're back guarantee this is great
full forty days money-back guarantee
this is perfect
love to see that I'd make that even
bigger have some kind of symbol or
something here so that people can
quickly see that because that's gonna
get lost in the shuffle here household
remedy practitioners Remini fda patent
okay
this page is okay to read i try to break
it up with some pictures that describe
each of these different sections to make
it just a little bit easier you have
testimonials up here on the right though
this is great the challenge here though
is gonna get lost
this is chunked up text and hard to read
and you've got so many pictures that my
eye is gonna gravitate to the flower the
product the pills here and then the
product again so i'd recommend if you
can trying to get pictures of each of
these people and showcase them at least
of the the you know maybe this doctors
well-known put his picture up on there
other people here you know beverly you
may not want to have their picture
associated with it but if you can I try
to put picked up people's pictures on it
so it'll get people's eye to go to the
page well that's a good step let's see
what else is next let's look at the
about us so the about us I'm expecting
to look to learn a little bit about your
company so welcome to the blessed seed
specialist producers of the highest
quality black seed products la blah blah
so I don't know who you are right people
like to buy from people so it's
important for this website for every
business owner to have a page on your
site especially if it's called about us
that talks about you right show your
picture show why you started this
business why did you get into the
blessed seed company did you have an
illness that this thing really helped
you with what's your personal story why
are you passionate about it if you can
let that passion come through in text or
in video or with your pictures then it's
gonna make people believe passions like
a fever if you believe in a strongly
other people are gonna catch it so
you've got to explain your story and put
it up on the site that should be one of
your best marketing methods is
passionately telling your story and why
you started this business let's keep
reading
so money-back guarantee that's great
our oil is checked by medical herbalist
dr. Antoine huije so who is this guy who
is Antoine poojaís I want to know you
should have his picture up here you
should have his bio if he's well
respected he has papers written you
should have all that information up here
to again add credibility because what
this website is missing is a lot of
credibility you say it's going to heal
everything in the world right that's a
huge bold statement that nobody's going
to believe so you've got to show you
have some credible people behind you who
are with your business and that's gonna
be all here on the about Us page so you
got to fix up this page for sure next
research this is something people going
to be interested in if they bother
spending some time on the site they're
going to know what's the research
discovered in Germany little known you
secure for a famous show horse and
politician with asthma so who is the
show horse who's this politician right
asthma you have to give details if you
just summarize people aren't gonna
believe it you have to link to articles
that are credible that say this famous
politician and this show horse use black
seed oil and they got cured that's when
people want to see I'd even try to have
a picture of them you know something
that can quickly draw the attention and
you have to be able to have that
information otherwise people will not
believe the information you put it up
here on the site let's keep reading the
interest that was created from these
cures was painting from an Egyptian
company to help the doctor and his
daughter cure their horse helped the
doctor and his daughter cure their horse
so who is the doctor we haven't talked
about a doctor here yet so it's
confusing people are gonna read that
first paragraph a little bit of the
second and they're gone if they are
confused it's not going to make sense to
them they're not gonna waste their time
you're going up against huge competition
right medical supplements is a humongous
industry can be highly profitable you
can make a ton of money on it you got to
do it right you have to tell the story
in a way that makes sense for people who
is this doctor you reference a doctor
and a horse and a famous politician
without giving details on this page I
want to see I want to see logos of media
outlets that I recognize I want to see
logos
universities that have done studies I
want to see links off to reputable pages
that talk about this none of that is
existing here the only picture is of
your product here in the middle so again
I'm gonna say this is BS I don't believe
it I'm not going to come back the bigger
your claim is the more you promise and
this is a huge claim right we can help
solve every illness in the world the
bigger claim is the more you need proof
to back it up
credible testimonials and recognize
proof that's sure that it works
otherwise people are going to back out
and they're not going to come back let's
check out while we wait just look at the
blog page you see what's happening here
so we've got our blog so today let's
check the date here today is July 23rd
as I'm doing this post the last blog
post was on June 3rd May 26 May 15 so
you need to post more if you want to
have a blog I mean it's great that it's
not you know 2012 here the date but you
need to post more this is not enough to
drive some traffic let's check out the
post to see what it's all about black
seed oil and health so here we're
talking a little bit about how it helps
right this is more benefit stapling
which is great allergies flu and fever
boils coughing asthma diarrhea this is
all this is all great stuff I try to put
in again some pictures to make it easier
to read with each blog post try to lead
off with a picture to make that a little
bit easier and you have enough content
you want to get at least 500 words of
content with each blog post that's
coming out I don't know if you're quite
there yet but you have some you have a
decent amount of content it's not just
like a hundred word mini post so that's
a good start
I definitely look at trying to do that
more and then using your blog as a way
to be able to drive SEO traffic and
people to the site so hopefully that
helped a lot of bad news in there but
you can fix it and if you really believe
in this product and you know it works
then do those things because you'll
bring more people to your website and
they'll be more likely to sign on the
dotted line put their visa card in and
pay you for your product for those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up
below makes you want to do more videos
for you and if you have a comment about
this video or question for your own
business I'd love to hear from you I
really enjoy seeing the comments coming
in it's one of the best parts of my day
it really is so please leave a comment
below thank you so much and I'll see you
on the next episode